bridget wilson sampras was once a
regular fixture on our screens
but her acting career has dwindled over
the past decade join us
as we explore why she stepped back from
hollywood despite being a major
sensation
born bridget wilson and raised in a
small town in coastal oregon
she competed in the miss teen usa
pageant at age 16.
wilson won the contest and became only
the second ever girl from oregon to hold
the title
in a post-win interview wilson told
reporters that she hoped to pursue a
career in the entertainment industry
and credited her family with helping her
win the title she told the associated
press
i went in and i was going to give it my
best shot and whatever my best was
i was going to hope for the best there
are 51 beautiful girls here
i'm a sincere person and i believe in
myself and having my family here was a
help
bridget wilson sampras quickly secured a
small role and saved by the bell
and her popularity grew throughout the
early 90s after an appearance in the
arnold schwarzenegger schwarzenegger-led
blockbuster last action hero
wilson sampras was cast as adam
sandler's love interest in the movie
billy madison the role she's best known
for almost didn't happen due to her work
with sandler
but a twist of fate would make sure that
audiences always thought of wilson
sampras
when they thought of sonia blade
it's an honor to finally meet you sonia
though it was critically panned the
mortal kombat movie was a big deal for
the actor starring in it
wilson sampras initially lost out on the
role of sonia blade
to a then unknown cameron diaz as wilson
sampras told the hollywood reporter
i went back and auditioned and met with
him so many times
probably seven i kept going back and
going back the decision was taken out of
wilson sampras's hands when she was cast
in billy madison
plus the producers had been wowed by
diaz in the mask
diaz trained to play sonia blade while
wilson sampras shot her film with adam
sandler
a producer on mortal kombat told the
hollywood reporter as soon as we saw the
dailies from the mask
there was no question that cameron diaz
was a star
we put her into training because she had
not really done this kind of martial
arts work before
she broke her wrist right before
shooting to the point where she couldn't
do the martial arts stunts we needed
with that stroke of diaz's bad luck
wilson sampras finally ended up landing
the part of sonya blade
while other cast members had months to
train for the film
wilson sampras had to work on her
fighting on set in thailand
she also had a health scare after
arriving on set and told the hollywood
reporter
in the very beginning i dislocated my
shoulder i did a partial dislocation but
it was weird because i was totally fine
they popped it back in and we kept going
it was all good
some people might expect tales of diva
behavior from a former pageant queen who
no longer works in hollywood
but all signs point toward bridget
wilson sampras being a trooper on the
set of mortal kombat
the actress told the hollywood reporter
i did all of my own stunts in all my own
fighting which was awesome
i didn't have as long to prepare as
everyone else did because they were able
to work with the trainers for a few
weeks
prior to the filming after mortal kombat
and billy madison
the roles came fast for wilson sampras
the horror flick i know what you did
last summer kept her busy
and she closed out the 90s with a few
minor parts before starring in the
remake
of house on haunted hill her last major
role came in 2001
when she appeared opposite jennifer
lopez and matthew mcconaughey in the
romantic comedy
the wedding planner during this time she
was also dating tennis superstar pete
sampras
who would change the course of her life
i think you know what i'm talking about
the actress married 14-time grand slam
winner pete sampras in 2000
the pair met by chance after sampras
spotted her at a los angeles movie
theater
he explained to instyle magazine i said
to my friend
half kidding i'd love to meet her the
friend introduced the couple and the
rest is history
the pair dated for nine months before
sampras proposed at his los angeles home
16 weeks later they held their wedding
in the backyard
sampras rented a massive tent to cover
his private tennis court
and turned it into a reception hall in
style reported that even elton john
dropped by the ceremony to play a
surprise 45-minute set
wilson sampras told the publication
that's one of my most
vivid memories of the wedding sampras
also revealed to in style that he was
ready to step out of the spotlight with
his new wife
and said when you win matches it's a
short-lived high
this was something i was committing to
for life tennis will one day stop
but i'll always have bridget that's the
biggest reward of all
the sampras's marriage has endured for
two decades
since that ceremony in their home the
couple went on to have two sons
christian sampras was born in 2002 and
ryan sampras followed in 2005. meanwhile
pete retired from professional tennis in
2002
after besting his career-long rival
andre agassi
in the finals of that year's u.s open
bridget wilson sampras continued to act
sparingly in the years after her sons
were born
but interviews from around the time of
her final film made it clear
that she was ready to live a quieter
life outside of hollywood
she told pregnancy magazine for now i
want to be there when the boys wake up
and i want to be there to put them in
bed wilson sampras didn't enjoy being
apart from her children
and she shared that feeling with the
magazine she explained
it was very hard for me to leave my kids
it was just devastating to have to get a
babysitter that wasn't family we went
through some nightmare experiences with
babysitters
but when you find that right person to
still be willing to go out to dinner and
not lose your relationship with your
husband
that was work for me i was like i love
you in all honey but
i'm busy i got my babies while she's
almost
certainly gotten better about separation
in the decades since
wilson sampras has not yet returned to
acting
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite celebrities are coming
soon subscribe to our youtube channel
and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one